The complex conjugate of 1 plus 9 I is just 1 minus 9 I. Now let's find their
product. Having a bunch of 1's in here actually makes our multiplication pretty
easy. I like that. Now you just need to simplify this final term and combine
like terms. Notice already we can see these 2 terms, negative 9 I and positive 9
I. Cancel one another out just like we had happen with our previous conjugate
pair multiplied together. I would like to pause at this step for a second where
we have 1 minus 81 i squared and note that this is a difference of 2 squares.
This is actually what we would expect to get when we are multiplying things like
this together. Remember that we learned quite early on in the course that when
we multiply something in the form a plus b times a minus b. We get a squared
minus b squared. This is exactly what's happening here. 1 is equal to 1 times 1
or a squared, and 81i squared is equal to 9i, the quantity squared. Now of
course, we can simplify 81i squared because this is just a real number. Number.
I squared is just negative 1. And negative 81 times negative 1 is positive 81,
so our answer is 82.